- We're gonna go ahead
and grab our Chrome Books,
we're gonna log in.
- Good morning.
- My name is Brooke Hogan,
I've been teaching for nine years.
I teach seventh grade
math, science, and health.
I try and get to know each
and every one of my students
on a personal level.
Good job.
Awesome.
So that they know that I
recognize them as a human being
and as a person, not just as
my student within my room.
Log in to Khan Academy.
I use Khan on an almost every day basis,
at least every other day.
You guys will see that I have assigned
you guys two assignments.
I will give them as assignments,
I have given them as quizzes.
The kids love using Khan
as quizzes because I allow
them one retake, so if they
don't like their score,
'cause they get their score at the end,
then they're like, I wanna retake it.
Alright, let's get to work.
When I assign an assignment,
I go back and I look
at the data on the reports tab.
With Khan in my classroom
and having that accessibility
in my classroom on a daily
basis, it really allows me to
work with small groups within
our instructional time.
- We don't know how to do the ink one.
- Those kids who need
that reteaching or to be,
have some concepts reinforced
within my instructional time.
Yeah, nice work.
Good job.
My students love it.
They absolutely love Khan.
When I say, on any given
day, okay guys, we're gonna
work on Khan today, yes!
I hear them starting to
challenge each other, like oh
what are you going to work on?
Oh I'm gonna work on this,
I'm gonna work on this.
Just in taking practice
tests, their math scores have
jumped so much.
Not only their math scores,
but I've seen their confidence
go up a lot.
Perfect!
Awesome.
Perfect, perfect.
I love seeing the light
bulbs go off on my kids'
faces when they finally
understand a concept
and they get it.
You see that excitement,
they're like, I got it!
And I'm like, yes!
I really want them to be able
to transfer the knowledge
that they learn in the
classroom and be able to
transfer it to their real lives.
Yay, perfect.
Perfect, perfect.